[Music]
I want to spend my life
mending broken people.
removing
pain.
Lord, let my words
heal a heart that hurts.
I want to spend my life,
mending broken people.
I want to spend my life
meeting broken people.
Hello, welcome to 3ABN Today Bible Q&A.
My name is Angela Lom King. I'm glad
that you've tuned in today. When we
travel, people tell us this is one of
their favorite programs. And I hope it's
your favorite program, too. Well, we are
here to answer your questions. But
before we do so, thank you for your
prayers and your support of this
worldwide ministry which is going into
all the world, giving you the gospel of
Jesus Christ. Well, I'm just going to
share a little thought with you. Nothing
less than a whole Bible can make you a
whole Christian. So, we do need the word
of God to guide our lives every day. I
know my husband and I, we were reading
our devot our Bible this morning and it
just encourages us. It lifts us closer
to the throne of God. And so, I am
encouraging you to pick up the word
right now and join us. Well, we have a
distinguished panel with us. We have
Shelley Quinn. Welcome, Shelly.
>> My joy. Thank you so much for sending in
your questions. They're fun to answer.
>> You enjoy this program, don't you?
>> Yes. Derell Thomas, welcome.
>> Thank you. It's a pleasure to join you
guys again and uh to find answers from
God's word.
>> Yes, we do. And in front of me, my
sweetheart. Welcome, honey.
>> I tried to match you, babe. Yes. Great
to be here to answer the word of God.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, if you have a question
and you'd like to turn in your question,
you can email us at bibleqa
at3abn.tv TV
or that you can email us or if you want
to text, send a text in, text it at
6182283975
or if you're a person that really likes
to use Instagram. You can go by saying
go to 3ABN
official. Okay. And before we go on, I'm
going to ask Derell, would you please
open with prayer?
>> Sure. Thank you.
>> Dear heavenly father, we thank you for
this privilege to come to you in prayer
uh to ask for the wisdom and power of
your holy spirit to speak through us as
we seek to answer the questions of our
viewers and also as we seek to know your
will moving forward and as we approach
the return of your son Jesus Christ. We
pray that our hearts will be knit to you
and knit together in the name of Jesus.
And we just pray that you will continue
to guide each and every person who needs
to hear these answers uh that they may
surrender their lives to Jesus. Please
draw them close to you and please bless
uh this program. We pray in Jesus' name.
Amen.
>> Amen. Thank you. As as Seventh Day
Adventists, we have always been known as
people of the book. And today is no
exception. We are going to go to the
book, the word of God. And we're going
to start with my husband, Pastor John
Lomang.
>> Here's your question. What can you tell
me about the Niclatians? This is from
Thirsten in Tennessee.
>> Yeah. Or thirsten, Tennessee.
>> Okay. Well, thank you. It's the Nicole
actually.
>> And there's a lot the Bible says about
them, but in various ways. I'll go ahead
and read Revelation 2 14 and 15. And
then I'll outline five things the Bible
talks about about the nickelutans.
>> But I have a few things against you
because you have there those who hold
the doctrine of Balum who taught Bailo
to put a stumbling block before the
children of Israel to eat things
sacrificed to idols and to commit sexual
immorality.
Thus you also have those who hold the
doctrine of the nicicoatans and then
it's so bad which things I hate. Now
there are two statements. Revelation 2:6
and Revelation 2:15 to the church of
Ephesus the Lord said
that doctrine among them he hated their
deeds. The church of Pergamus they
tolerated their doctrines. The
nickelotin had a a broad application and
broad influence. and the nickelatin
teachings was dangerous enough for
Christ to single them out. One of the
reasons why let me talk about the
historical nature. Nicol nickelotans
come from two words in the Greek. Nikos
meaning conqueror and leos meaning
people. When you study the history of
the nicicoatans they conquered people or
more specifically in the context of the
Greek they dominated people. They were
known as people that abused Christian
liberty. Secondly, promoted compromise
with pagan practices. And thirdly, they
taught that the sins of the flesh did
not affect one's salvation if faith was
still professed. Can you imagine that? I
could live anyhow, live immorally as
long as I profess faith. Well, that's
not the case. That's why I just read
Revelation 2:14.
A part of their doctrines was they
supported sexual immorality. And so they
said, "It's not going to affect your
standing before God as long as you are
faithful." Well, you can't be faithful
and live sexually immoral. Uh the
spiritual hierarchy, some of their
interpreters suggested that clerical
domination,
leaders ruling harshly over believers
instead of serving them. That was
something that they were known for. They
ruled their people. You do this or you
do that, not we are servants together in
the work of Christ. Thirdly, the reason
why God hates them is they talked about
sin is tolerable. When Jesus says he
came to save his people from their sins,
not in their sins, the nickelans
promoted the idea that you could live
like the world yet remain saved. And we
know that's not true. Also, their
teachings destroyed holiness.
It mocks God's grace. It enslaves
believers under the sin while giving
them false sense of assurance. In other
words, everything's going to be all
right. How you live really doesn't
matter. But Romans chapter 6 verse 1 and
2 says opposite. What shall we say then?
Say then shall we continue in sin that
grace may abound? Certainly not. How
shall we who died to sin live any longer
in it? So in the modern application of
the nicicoatin's
cheap grace theology claiming salvation
while repentance and obedience is
lacking. Secondly, worldly compromise.
The church blending with the world
secular culture and tolerating
immorality. That's why there's no such
thing as gay priests. Not in not not in
God's church. The third thing is
spiritual abuse. Leaders exalting
themselves above the people rather than
serving them. And the Bible speaks
against that. We must be servants of the
most high God and servants of one
another, not dominating. So in a short,
the excuse of sin under the guise of
grace, promoting idolatry and sexual
immorality and possibly fostering a
hierarchy that dominated believers
rather than served. And in a nutshell,
Jesus says, "You also have those who
hold the doctrine of the nickelans, and
now you know why he hated them."
Revelation 2:15.
>> Amen.
>> Wow. Isn't that like today, these last
days?
>> Almost like once save always save. I
could do anything I want.
>> Anything I want
>> and the Lord doesn't mind.
>> Yeah. On the cont. Wow. Thank you for
that.
>> Okay, Derell,
here's your question. If Adam and Eve
were created first, what about cavemen
who were around millions of years ago?
We have evidence of cavemen before Adam
and Eve. Can you please explain? This is
from Karen in Illinois. Well, thank you
Karen for your question. And to answer
it directly, the Bible paints a picture
that is strikingly different from the
idea that cavemen existed millions of
years before Adam and Eve were created.
Also, there's on ongoing DNA testing
that has shown that cavemen and
Neanderthalss were actually humans after
all. But to get back to your question,
in the very first chapter of the of the
Bible, we are given a clear record of
the origins not just of human life, but
of all life on the earth. From the
tiniest bacteria to the plants and
animals that we see all around us.
According to Genesis 1, there was a
definite undisputable time when all life
began. We read in Genesis 1:es 1 and two
that in the beginning that's a starting
point God created the the heavens and
the earth and then it says the earth was
without form and void. So the earth was
in its initial state was unformed, empty
and uninhabitable for both humans and
all earthly life forms. And that changed
only when God began his creative work on
day one of creation week. The New
Testament confirms this truth saying all
things were made through him and without
him nothing was made that was made
according to John 1:3 speaking of Jesus.
So this tells us that all life on earth
came from God and Genesis 1 shows that
this took place during a definite
literal 6 day creation week and not
before that time. So when we encounter
what may seem like scientific facts such
as life existing for millions of years
before Adam and Eve, we must measure
those claims by what the Bible says
rather than measuring the Bible but what
by what science says. Science has its
strengths but history has shown it is
not infallible. For example, for
centuries, people believed in what was
called the scientific theory of
spontaneous generation. This is the idea
that life could arise from non-living
matter. So, it was once thought that
maggots simply appeared in rotting meat
or that mice could come from piles of
grain or rags. And this was even taught
by prominent
>> uh figures like Aristotle. It wasn't
until the 17th and 19th centuries that
experiments overturned this belief that
they thought was a fact. Franchesco
Ready in 1668
showed that maggots come from fly eggs,
not from the meat itself. And then
Louisie Pasture in 1861 confirmed that
microorganisms
came from other microorganisms,
not spont spontaneously from non-living
matter. So, what's the lesson in all of
this? Science can uh can change its
conclusions, but God's word never
changes.
>> Where the Bible and science agree, we
can rejoice. Hallelujah.
>> But where they disagree, we lean more
heavily on the unshakable foundation of
scripture.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. And we are fearfully and
wonderfully made, aren't we?
>> Amen. That's right. Amen.
>> Thank you so much, Darell, for that.
Okay, Shellyley,
here's your question. If someone is
already baptized by immersion in the
name of the Father, the Son, and the
Holy Spirit, why does the Seventh Day
Adventist Church want that person to be
rebaptized? This is from a viewer in New
York.
>> Well, thank you. If in if someone has
already been
>> baptized by immersion in a biblical
manner.
>> Yes.
>> The 7th Day Adventist Church only
recommends rebaptism for two spiritual
and biblical reasons. The first is
receiving new light. And let me explain
that. If the baptized believer later
learns
and accepts distinctive biblical
teaching that represents the whole
message of Christ and they realize that
they weren't they didn't know the gospel
when they were baptized. They may choose
rebaptism as an act of publicly
committing to enter into that covenant
life with Christ. the biblical basis in
Acts 19 1-5. Paul met some brothers at
Ephesus. They'd been baptized by John
the Baptist. They didn't know about the
Holy Spirit. They really didn't know
much about Jesus. And so, he teaches
them new truths. And what does he do? He
rebaptizes them. Now, the second reason
is spiritual renewal. Uh you would
recommend rebaptism for spiritual
renewal after apostasy. If somebody was
a baptized member and they openly
departed from faith in Christ and or his
teachings, that means they broken
covenant with him. And so rebaptism
marks that repentance and restoration.
Let me say this. Many people
don't understand what baptism means when
they get baptized. And I'll say it
because I know I was baptized at 13
years old. It was the time.
>> I didn't understand it. I was baptized
again because I went I I thought I
hadn't been baptized in the right
manner. And I grew up being taught if
you weren't baptized just right, you're
going to hell.
>> So I got baptized again. Then I when I
was about 28, I got baptized because I
went down to join a church. It was a a
bapt It had been a Baptist church and
they dunked me before I knew what was
going on.
>> I mean, it was just to join. They
thought it was joining the church.
You're not baptized into a church.
You're baptized into Christ.
>> But it's more than a ser um a ceremonial
washing. Baptism is a public confession
that you're entering into a covenant
life with Christ. Romans 6:34 says, "As
many as were baptized into Christ Jesus
were baptized into his death, therefore
we were buried with him through baptism
into death, that just as Christ was
raised from the dead by the glory of the
father, even so we should walk in
newness of life." I finally was baptized
because I understood the scripture. That
was before I became an Adventist. I came
into the Adventist church by profession
of faith.
>> Amen. So, how many times were you
baptized?
>> Four.
>> The last one took because I knew what it
meant.
>> You're completely drunk and washed.
>> Yes. Yes. And we're following Jesus,
right? Yeah. He did that as an example.
>> He was perfect.
>> Yeah. Amen. Thank you so much, Shelley.
Okay. Pastor John,
would you please explain Hebrews 4:9?
And this is from Christine in Nevada.
>> Christine, Hebrews 4:9 read as follows.
There remains therefore a rest
>> for the people of God. And I'm going to
end by reading the amplified after I
explain those three contexts. Love the
amplified.
>> Now, it reflects the reality that the
Sabatismos,
the keeping of the Sabbath remains.
That's the one of the focuses. You see
this this text covers three particular
rests the Bible talks about. Let me
break those down. The first one is in
Genesis chapter 2 verse 2 and three when
the Bible says thus the heavenly and the
earth and all the host of them were
finished and on the seventh day God
ended this work and then God rested
blessed and sanctified the seventh day.
That's the first application of this
verse. So the seventh day Sabbath
established at the end of the sixth day
creation week was it still remains there
remains therefore a Sabbatismos
for the people of God. So if you're a
child of God the Sabbath rest the day
blessed at the end of creation week is
still intact. It remains for the people
of God. That's the first one. The second
one comes from the Canaan rest. Hebrews
4:6, it talks about they did not enter
in because of unbelief. So they didn't
enter into, he said, they would not
enter into my rest. When you read
Hebrews chapter 4:6, they would not
enter into his rest. That's the Canaan
rest. Israel was promised rest in the
land of Canaan. But many failed to enter
because of unbelief. So they never
benefited from that rest, the Canaan
rest. They never experienced that.
because of their unbelief, they did not
enter in. So that's the second one. When
we are believers in Christ, we enter
into a spiritual Canaan-like rest.
Resting in the promises of God, resting
in the knowledge that he delivers us, he
sustains us in our journey, and he
brings us to our place of rest. And the
third one builds on that with Matthew
11:28.
Come unto me all you who labor and he
are heavy ladened and I will give you
rest. That is Matthew 11:28. Which mean
Jesus invites us to come to me and I
will give you rest. That rest is not
found anywhere else other than in Jesus.
Not in your house, not in your
education, not in your income, not even
in your church service. That is only
found in Jesus. So summarizing the
Sabbath rest remains, that verse
supports that. So when the writer of
Hebrews puts that he is authorizing all
three as continuing to remain enter into
Christ's weekly rest of the Sabbath his
rest of following him because of your
belief you have rest in Christ. And
thirdly when you are heavy ladened come
to him and he will give you rest. So
therefore Hebrews 4:9 amplified. So are
there still awaiting a full and complete
Sabbath rest reserved for the true
people of God.
Amen. And in Isaiah 66:23,
from one new moon to another and from
one Sabbath to another, right? That's
right.
>> All mankind will come to worship before
me, says
>> that eternal rest.
>> Ah,
>> in the kingdom.
>> That's Yes. Amen. Thank you so much.
Okay, Derell.
Will we remember our life here on earth
when we go to heaven or the new earth?
This is Frank from California.
>> Thank you, Frank. That's a a great
question and it's one that many of us
think about as we think what eternity is
going to be like. And we can picture the
scene that God himself describes in
Isaiah 65:17 where he says, "For behold,
I create new heavens and a new earth,
and the former shall not be remembered
or come to mind."
Now in this passage, the former things
refer to the painful results of sin that
have entered the world since the fall of
Adam and Eve. In verses 17 to 25 of this
chapter, God lists some of those painful
things like crying, weeping, death, and
harm. And then Revelation 21:4 expands
on this truth, saying that God will wipe
away every tear from their eyes. There
shall be no more death nor sorrow nor
crying. There shall be no more pain for
the former things have passed away. So
from these promises we understand that
God will remove all memory of sin's pain
from the redeemed. But what about the
good memories from this life? Will those
also disappear? I believe scripture
gives us a reason to say no. The Bible
not only speaks of the erasing of the
memory of sin, but also of the
preservation or even immortalization
of the righteous deeds of God's people.
Malachi 3:16 tells us that those who
feared the Lord spoke to one another,
and the Lord listened and heard them.
So, a book of remembrance was written
before him for those who fear the Lord
and who meditate on his name. Mhm.
>> So here God reveals to us a book of
remembrance that is kept before him. And
in Hebrew when it says so a book of
remembrance was written before him for
those who fear the Lord. That phrase can
mean both that it is a record about
those who fear the Lord but also that as
the scripture itself says that is a is a
record for them. In other words, it's
something kept on their behalf. So in
other words, God keeps an eternal record
of the good he has worked through his
people so that in the ages to come they
will have a constant reminder of his
grace and of the ways he used them for
his glory. In eternity the pain will be
gone but the joy of knowing how God
worked and in and through our lives will
remain forever. The former things that
vanish are the sorrows of sin. While the
book of remembrance ensures that the
righteous deeds and deeds inspired by
the spirit of the Lord will never fade
from God's mind or from ours.
>> Finally, one of the greatest reminders
from this world will be the wounds that
Christ wears in his body as a reminder
of the cost of our redemption and his
infinite love for us. As Isaiah 49:16
says in these wonderful words, "See, I
have inscribed you on the palms of my
hands."
>> Amen.
>> Praise the Lord. We will have a memory
of what Christ has done for us for all
eternity.
>> Amen. Beautiful.
>> Wonderful.
>> What about our sins? Cast into the
depths of the sea.
>> Praise the Lord.
>> It's blotted out, right?
>> Delete.
>> Delete. Delete. Delete. And it's Yeah.
That's that's one thing you don't want
ever to be on you. No. So, praise the
Lord for that. Thank you so much,
Darell.
>> Shellyley, here's your question.
H Okay. Is there such a thing as a
person dying too soon? Doesn't God have
our lives, steps, and situations
pre-ordained? This is from Mike in
Michigan.
Mike, God fornows
>> every detail of our lives, but that is
different from predestining us to every
act or accident. We live in a world of
sin where there's disease, accidents,
and violence that can cut life short.
It's not God's ideal, but he can bring
redemption even from that tragedy.
Jeremiah 29:11 said God says that he has
a plan for our lives. And I'm going to
tell you, he said it's a plan to prosper
you, to give you a future. But God does
not control us like puppets. His plan is
so much better than what many of us are
living because we haven't yielded to his
control. The Bible teaches that God is
all knowing. He is sovereign and he has
given humanity freedom of choice. He
designs the path. He provides guidance
if we'll accept it. He strengthens our
steps. But he never overrides our will.
He does not predestin
every event in our lives in a way that
takes away our responsibility
for our own actions or even for the
effects of living in a sinful world.
Psalm 37:23 says the steps of a good man
are ordered by God. That means they're
established. They're made firm. They're
directed by God. And then it says he
delights in their ways. But God knows
the end from the beginning. He knows the
day and the hour that we're going to die
just because he knows what choices we're
going to make. Here's the good thing.
Nothing can take us without his
awareness. While God allows freedom of
choice, the natural consequences of a
broken world, scripture assures us that
no one dies outside of his notice. In
Matthew 10:29 through31, Jesus said,
"Even a sparrow falling to the ground,
he takes notice of. How much more does
he know what's going on in your life?"
And to us, a person,
when someone dies that's close to us,
especially if they're young or it's
unexpected, it feels too soon. But
Isaiah 57:1 says, "The righteous
perishes and no man takes it to heart.
Merciful men are taken away while no one
considers that the righteous is taken
away from evil." So here's the point.
from God's
eternal perspective, if you will.
Death is nothing more than asleep.
That's what Jesus said.
>> We sleep till the resurrection. So God,
even if you think it's an early death,
God knows what's going to happen, but he
didn't predetermine that step.
>> Amen. Amen. Beautiful. My mom used to
say the from Ecclesiastes 7:7, "Why die
before your time?" Amen.
>> Used to tell us that why take drugs and
all these things. Why die before your
time? Everyone has a time. So yes, thank
you for that, Shelley. Beautiful. Now
maybe you've just tuned in and you said,
"Wow, I have a question I'd like to send
in." Okay, you can do so. You can email
us right now to at uh bibleqa3abn.tv
or you can send in a text. We make it
easy at 6182283975
or maybe on an Instagram person. You can
go at 3ABN
underscore official. So send in your
questions. We'd love to answer them for
you from the word of God. Okay, Pastor
John, here's yours. This is an
interesting one. I was discussing with
other seventh day Sabbathke keepers and
received some insight from a member of
the church of God. From what I saw,
their main difference seems to be their
non-belief in EG White as a prophet. Are
there other significant differences?
This is from Artell.
>> Yes, there are significant differences.
Let me just bring some of those out.
>> I I actually looked it up and I found
quite a bit to talk about. So I decided,
well, rather than going through all the
details that you might very much forget,
let me encourage you. You can actually
go to the internet and do this search
yourself and put in Google list the
differences between Seventh Day
Adventist and the true or the church of
God. Now, first of all, let me just
start something say something that's
really important when it comes to
following Jesus. Let's all start right
there. That's a similarity that all
Christians have.
>> You know, Jesus even talked about those
who were not following him. And he said,
"Other sheep I have that are not of this
fold." John 10:16. But he didn't stop
there. He said, "Them also I must bring,
and they will hear my voice, and they'll
be onefold and one shepherd." Revelation
also talks about a a group of people
that the devil is very angry with, and
he defines those as those who keep the
commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus Christ. Now
the church of God, they keep the
commandments of God the Sabbath, but
they deny the inspiration of the
spiritual gift given to the church
through the ministry of Ellen White. So
what is the testimony of Revelation
19:10? For the testimony of Jesus is the
spirit of prophecy. That's the gift act
of she's not the spirit of prophecy, but
like the prophets of old, that gift is
operating in the church through her
ministry. And that gift continues even
though she's passed on. There are many
who have that gift as they operate. And
the Lord reveals to them as the Bible
says in the book of Acts in Joel chapter
2, God will pour out his spirit on all
flesh. Young men shall see visions. Old
men shall dream dreams. I've been having
a lot of dreams lately. So therefore,
that categorizes me right away. But here
are some of the similarities and
uniquenesses. Similarity, Sabbath
observance. They both reject the
immortal soul doctrine. and they both
emphasize obedience in God's law. Key
difference, Seventh Day Adventists
believe in the investigative judgment,
Ellen White as a as a messenger, a
strong prophetic framework, which we
have, health reform, which they don't
emphasize, and end time Sabbath rest and
Sabbath Sunday test. The Church of God's
seventh day, they reject her
inspiration. They don't believe in the
ministry of Christ as it relates to
1844. uh they downplay the investigative
judgment and they have less emphasis on
lifestyle reform and prophetic
interpretation. The SDA church is
worldwide highly organized denomination
a general conference structure unified
doctrines officially agreed upon in the
28 fundamental beliefs. But the church
of God 7th day historically they are
more fragmented meaning you might find
one here and one there but they're not
connected together. fragmented with
independent groups, notably their
Denver-based General Conference and also
other branches. They are less organized
uniformity in their doctrinal unity
compared to 7th Day Adventist Church. In
other words, they have doctrinal
differences as they go from church to
church. But wherever you find a Seventh
Day Adventist church, we are uniformed
under the same 28 fundamentals. That's
the short list.
>> But do the work and you'll find there's
so many more things that make a huge
difference.
>> Wow. I didn't know they didn't they
believe about the immortal soul like us.
>> I didn't know that.
>> Like wow I didn't know
>> even Jehovah's Witnesses believe that
you don't die in heaven.
>> They know. Yeah.
>> But there are a lot of things they
reject like the divinity of Christ as
equal with God.
>> Yeah.
>> Anyway,
>> and another book we like to read is um
Oswwell Chambers
>> very much inspired man of God. So there
are many wonderful books we can read.
All right. Thank you. Okay. Derell, who
are the two witnesses of Revelation 11?
This is from Anthony in Ohio.
>> Well, thank you, Anthony. Uh, the short
answer to your question is that the two
witnesses are best understood as
representing the writings contained
within the Old and New Testaments of the
Bible.
>> How do we reach this conclusion?
Revelation 11 itself gives important
clues about who or what these witnesses
represent. Mhm. In verse three, the
witnesses are said to prophesy just as
scripture presents God's truth across
time from the distant past to the
present and into the distant future. In
verses five and six, the witnesses then
perform signs and call judgments against
those who oppose them.
>> Specifically, like Moses, they turn
water to blood and bring plagues. And
like Elijah, they call down fire from
heaven and shut up the heavens so that
no rain falls. Now Moses and Elijah
symbolized two essential components of
scripture, the law and the prophets.
This term was used as shorthand for the
inspired writings of the Bible. You see
in John 1:45, Philip found Nathaniel and
said to him, "We have found him of whom
Moses in the law and also the prophets
wrote." And who did they write about?
Jesus of Nazareth, the son of Joseph. So
what Moses and the prophets wrote
concerning Jesus is what we now call the
scriptures.
>> In Jesus' time, it was often just
referred to as the law and the prophets.
So in this way the writings of the old
and new testaments echo and witness or
testify to what God and Christ revealed
to the inspired writers of the Bible.
The two witnesses then are described as
fulfilling the work of scripture. In
addition, the witnesses reflect Christ
himself who is called the word of God.
In Revelation 19:13,
uh, it describes him as clothed with a
robe dipped in blood and his name is
called the Word of God.
Just like Christ, the witnesses are
persecuted, killed, and silenced for a
time only to be raised to life and taken
up to heaven, thus vindicating their
work. The imagery of Moses, Elijah, and
Christ is intentional. The two witnesses
represent both scripture in its entirety
and also the author and subject of
scripture himself Jesus Christ. Their
work testifies to Christ as the living
word and simultaneously to the word of
God as revealed through scripture.
>> Thus to restate the two witnesses
symbolize the writings of the old and
new testaments. And historically, one
dramatic fulfillment of Revelation 11
occurred during the French Revolution.
From 1793 to 1797,
France openly rejected the Bible,
abolished religion, and exalted human
reason in its place. The scriptures were
temporarily, in a sense, dead within the
public sphere. Yet, just as Revelation
foretold, the writings of God's word
rose again to prominence, pointing
people to salvation and preparing them
for the soon return of Christ.
>> Amen.
>> Beautiful. Boy, the word of God is rich,
isn't it?
>> Yes.
>> Full of full of wonderful jewels. Thank
you so much for that.
>> Okay, Shelley, this is this is a quick
to the point question. On what day did
did God create the angels? This is from
Arthur in Pennsylvania.
>> Arthur, the angels already existed
before creation week. Job 38:4-7.
God is speaking to Job. He says, "Where
were you when I laid the foundation of
the earth? When the morning stars sang
together, and all the sons of God
shouted for joy." The morning stars and
the sons of God refer to the angels. And
you could look at Revelation 12:4 or Job
1:6 for that. They rejoiced when God
formed the earth, which means they were
created before the six days of our
world's creation. Angels are part of
God's broader
creative acts that he created before the
foundation of planet earth. They are
created beings. Be sure you know that.
Psalm 148:es 2 and 5 says, "Praise him
all his angels, for he commanded and
they were created.
Christ himself was their creator."
Colossians 1:16. By him, by Christ. All
things were created that are in heaven
and earth, visible and invisible,
whether thrones or dominions or
principalities or powers. So the angels
were brought into existence by Christ
before our earth. Why doesn't the Bible
mention them? You you realize Genesis is
focusing on the creation of our earth.
There are 2,000 years of history in just
the first 11 chapters of Genesis. Isn't
that mind-blowing?
>> Yeah.
>> So, they it just the Bible doesn't
explain when angels were created, but it
clearly indicates that they were created
before the foundation of the world as
part of God's heavenly creation. And we
just simply know they existed
beforehand. And they rejoiced when they
saw his work on earth.
>> Amen. They have a great work to do,
don't they? They're working right here
on this earth. The angels.
>> Wow. So many times when we're driving
and we could have gotten in a terrible
accident, we know God sent his angels to
help prevent that accident. That's
right. So yes, they have a great work to
do. Thank you so much, Shelley. Honey,
John, pastor, this is an interesting
question for a man.
>> Why are women allowed to preach from the
pulpit if the scriptures say they
shouldn't? This is from Jennifer in
Oklahoma.
>> I'm going to dive right in. 1
Corinthians chapter 14 is not about
prohibiting any gender. It's about order
in the service. Let me just start with
the book ends. I I'll begin with 1
Corinthians chapter 14 26. Here's what
the Bible says.
How is it then, brethren, whenever you
come together, each of you has a psalm,
has a teaching, has a tongue, has a
revelation, has an interpretation. And
then it starts, let all things be done
for edification. That's the one. Let's
go to the other book in verse 40. 1
Corinthians 14:4. Let all things be done
decently and in order. The whole of 1
Corinthians chapter 14 is about that is
verse 26 to verse 40 is about order.
Look at verse uh let's start with verse
28. It continues talking about
interpreting. If somebody speaks in the
tongue about an interpreter but if there
be no interpreter notice let him keep
silent in the church that's definitely
speaking about a man. Let him speak to
himself and to God. So if if there's
somebody speaking in an unknown tongue
and they have no interpreter let him.
whether male nor female. That's not a
gender-pecific terminology there as the
Bible often uses the word him. But
anybody could have that opportunity
because the Bible says in Acts chapter 2
verse1 17, I will pour out my spirit on
all flesh. Your sons and your daughters
shall prophesy. So that gift of prophecy
was available in the New Testament
church surely in the church of Corinth.
And the Bible says in 1 Corinthiansap
11:5,
"Every woman who prays or prophesies
with her head uncovered dishonors her
husband." It's not it's not prohibiting
her from prophesying. It's simply saying
when you do it, make sure that you're
covered. And the husband twofold, her
husband literally and Christ is the head
of her covering. And so let's go on
further. Look at the next verse, verse
30. This is talking about uh in 1
Corinthians chapter 14:30. But it but if
anything is revealed to another who sits
by, no longer gender specific, let the
first keep silent. Notice how silence,
silence, silence. They're talking about
order in the service. And now this one,
this is very interesting. I actually
studied this one many years ago. Verse
34. Let your women keep silent in the
church for they are not permitted to
speak. But if they are to be submissive
as the law also says. In other words,
when you study this, the Jewish church
was organized in such a way the women
and the men sat apart. If the rabbi was
speaking and he says something that did
not understand say the men are
downstairs, the women are in the balcony
or they're on the other side of the
curtain. Uh my wife would say, "John,
what did he say?" Right away the order,
the service is broken. Paul was
supporting order, not prohibiting anyone
to speak. So this is not about muffling
Christians and say only men have the
right to speak. This is simply about
order in the Christian church.
>> Wow. So women are allowed to speak.
>> Amen. Shelley Quinn.
>> Shel, I'll let you I woman thou wart
loose.
>> Amen. Jill, we have Jill Maronei
speaker. Wonderful.
God's got a place for Shel and she's
Amen. She does it very well.
>> We have Miriam, Anna.
>> Oh, so many.
>> The list goes on and on. There you go,
honey.
>> Derell, here's your question. Where is
God's throne in the heavenly sanctuary?
This is Barry all the way in South
Korea.
>> Barry, uh, thank you for your question.
And one of the most fasc fascinating
things about God's throne is that the
Bible does not describe it as a
stationary chair always remaining in the
same place forever.
>> Instead, it it's pictured as a somewhat
of a chariot throne capable of movement.
Ezekiel 1 describes it as having wheels
within wheels. And Daniel 7:9 says that
the throne was like a fiery flame
>> with wheels of burning fire. So rather
than thinking of God's throne as stuck
in one place, scripture shows that it
can move to different places in heaven
as God sees fit. And so that means that
instead of asking where the throne is at
at all times, it is better to ask where
the throne has been seen at different
times within uh the context of the
heavenly sanctuary. And one of the
clearest examples is found in Revelation
chapters 4 and 5. Mhm.
>> John is shown a throne room scene filled
with sanctuary imagery. And he records
in Revelation 4:2 that immediately I was
in the spirit and behold a throne set in
heaven and one sat on the throne.
>> And then a few verses later in verse 5,
it says that from the throne proceeded
lightnings, thunderings, and voices. And
note this. It says, "Seven lamps of fire
were burning before or in front of the
throne, which are the seven spirits of
God." So here's the key detail. Before
or in front of the throne were seven
burning lamps of fire. Then in
Revelation 5:8, the 24 elders fall down
before the throne holding golden bowls
full of incense, which are the prayers
of the saints. So both of these
elements, the lamps of fire and the
incense were connected to the holy place
of the earthly sanctuary which was
patterned after heavenly things. So the
golden lampstand provided uh provided
seven flames and the golden altar held
incense representing the prayers of
God's people. So John is not inventing
new imagery. He is pointing us back to
the sanctuary to show us that at this
moment in history in the confines of
Revelation 4 and 5, God's throne is
functioning in connection with the holy
place of the heavenly sanctuary. So
there's also a strong hint about its uh
the the the throne's position because in
the earthly tabernacle, the lampstand
was on the south side of the he of the
holy place and the table of showbread
stood on the north side of the holy
place. So since John s says that the
lamps were burning in front of the
throne, it suggests that the throne
itself had potential of being in the
place of where the table of showbread
would normally stand on the north side
of the holy place. Another way we we can
uh we know that Revelation 4 and 5 are
holy place scenes is that when we uh is
when we compare later visions in
Revelation 11:1 19 John says that the
temple of God was opened in heaven and
then at that time the ark of his
covenant was seen. That scene clearly
reveals the most holy place and it comes
in the context of judgment as seen in
Revelation 11:18.
In the earthly service, the ark was only
revealed once a year on the day of
atonement, the day of judgment.
Likewise, Daniel 7 also places God's
throne in the most holy place when the
court or the judgment was seated and the
books were opened. So the picture comes
together like this in Revelation chapter
4 and 5. God's throne is seen in the
holy place where Christ began his
ministry in heaven after his ascension.
Later in Revelation 11 and and Daniel
chapter 7, his throne is revealed in the
most holy place in connection with
judgment. The larger truth is that God's
throne is not bound to one single
location. It moves according to his will
and the unfolding of the plan of
redemption. So wherever his throne is
revealed in the holy place or the most
holy place, he is carrying forward his
work of saving his people for eternity.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you so much for that.
Wonderful. What a mighty God we serve.
>> Amen.
>> Shelley, you're going to take a little
more time on this question. This is
interesting.
I had a dream where the spirit asked me,
"Why don't you give God a chance?" How
do I give God a chance? This is from
Donna in Georgia.
>> Donna, the fact that you reached out to
me personally to answer this is very
significant to me. It sounds like God is
reaching out personally to you through
that dream. When the still small voice
of the Lord says, "Why don't you give
God a chance?" What he is inviting you
to do is to trust God with your heart,
to open your heart
>> and receive God's love.
>> He wants you to trust him with every
part of your life.
>> Giving God a chance is to give him
access to your life.
>> Yes.
>> And you know, we do this. We use the
word surrender. And some people, you
know, men think surrender is, "Oh, I
give up." and women, oh, I'm going to be
controlled. But surrender means that
you're yielding to God, that you're
going to let God lead and you follow.
You know, I mentioned earlier
when
God said in Jeremiah 29:11 through13, I
know the plans I have for you, Donna.
He's speaking to you. Plans to prosper
you, to give you a hope and a future.
And it's it's I just want to say this.
God's plan for your life,
>> God's plan for my life,
>> yes,
>> is better than the one we're living.
>> Amen.
>> You know, it's it's God has the best
plan for you. And I know I'm still, you
know, getting into the rhythm of his
plan.
>> But the scripture goes on in Jeremiah 29
>> in verse 12. It says, "Then," what do
you mean then? When
>> when you recognize God has a plan for
your life, then you will call upon me
and come and pray to me
>> and I will listen to you and you will
seek me and find me when you seek me
with all of your heart. I'm going to
give you I wished I had more time for
this four minutes. It's not enough, but
five quick steps. Please write these
down
>> to give God a chance. First, pray.
>> Amen. Just open your heart and talk to
him honestly.
>> Tell him about your fears, your
disappointments, your doubts, your
hopes.
>> Two, ask to be filled with the Holy
Spirit.
>> You know, Jesus said in Luke 11 and
verse 9, it's not just a one-time deal.
He says, "Ask and keep on asking, seek
and keep on seeking, knocking, keep on
knocking." And then he says in verse 13,
"How much more will the heavenly father
give the Holy Spirit to those who ask
and keep on asking?" We're leaky
vessels. We need to ask again.
>> Absolutely.
>> But the the thing that I want you to do,
the reason I want you to pray and ask is
because these are spiritual words,
spiritually discerned. You can't
understand Christ's message, nor do you
have the power to walk in obedience
without the Holy Spirit. So the third
step is yield. That's what we say when
we say surrender. It means yield your
will by saying Lord I'm willing to do
your will or
maybe Lord I'm willing to be made
willing to do your will.
lead me and use pray this scripture
Psalm 143:10
he David says teach me to do your will
for you are my God your spirit is good
lead me in the land of uprightness
and then here's the fourth step spend
time daily with God in his word Romans
10:17 says faith comes by hearing
hearing by the word of God Ask the Holy
Spirit to make it personal to you.
>> Five is to obey the truth that you
learn. Jesus said in John 14:15, "If you
love me, keep my commandments."
>> So even small steps of obedience,
obedience is the pathway to blessings of
God.
>> And what God is asking, Donna, is he
wants your heart. He wants you to love
him in return and give him a chance to
prove himself faithful. Let me tell you
something.
>> This is not a one-time act.
>> It's a daily choice
>> that we just say, Lord, I'm willing to
give you a chance.
>> Yes.
>> Oh, Father, fill me with your Holy
Spirit. Give me the power to walk in
obedience. Explain your word to me. Show
me the plan that you have for my life.
And Donna, I promise you, it's a good
one.
>> It's a good one. Oh, Shelly, that was
beautiful.
>> He wants to give us life and give it to
us more abundantly. Thank you so much.
Well, we're going to take a short break
and we will be right back.
>> If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
6182283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
[Music]
Be sure to include your name and where
you live and then watch 3ABN Bible Q&A
for answers from God's word.
Unlock a treasure trove of spiritual
content with the free 3ABN Plus app.
Download it from your app store today
and explore our ondemand programs, live
broadcasts, and more anytime, anywhere.
Whether you're on the go or at home, you
won't want to miss a moment of God's
word, join us and be blessed. Download
today.
Welcome back. We have a few closing
thoughts from these wonderful panelists
here. So, let's start. Okay, Shel. Let's
start with Shelley.
>> Okay. Well, I just I want to speak not
only to Donna. It's precious that the
Lord is reaching out to you personally,
but to all.
>> Yeah.
>> God wants all to be saved and come to a
knowledge of the Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ. Give God a chance. Say, "Lord,
help me trust you. Prove yourself to me.
He will."
>> Amen.
>> Derell. Uh and as we consider uh again
what will be what will be remembered uh
from this world in the the new earth uh
we can rejoice that uh Hebrews chapter
8:12 says for I will forgive their
wickedness and will remember their sins
no more.
>> Amen.
>> Beautiful. Amen.
>> And since I'm a man I'll just kind of
add more icing on on the issue about
women speaking in church. The Bible does
not prevent women at all from speaking.
Once again, Acts 2:1 17, the Lord is
pouring out his spirit on all flesh, and
women better say something. Let the
redeemed of the Lord say so.
>> You find on the Old Testament, you find
in the book of Acts chapter 18,
Priscilla along with Aquilla explains
the gospel more accurately to Apollos.
Her active teachings is a role that the
Bible affirms. Also, Titus told the
older women to instruct the younger
women in the sanctuary. And Paul talks
about Phoebe uh as as um in the role of
and Priscilla as the coworker. Uh
there's Old Testament, there's Miriam
the prophetus, Deborah hold of the
prophetus. So the Bible's not taking
away that gift from women at all. You
know, everybody's needed and the gospel
commission of Matthew 28 is to everyone
to go therefore and teach that Jesus is
coming again.
>> Amen.
>> Beautiful. Thank you panelists.
Wonderful. I hope you were blessed. I
was blessed in Psalm 119:1.
Your word I have hidden hidden in my
heart that I might not sin against thee.
Have a blessed day in Jesus.
[Music]
Good morning.